[Music]
My name
is Nurelle Base, and I
work at the Lycée Premiere. My name is Masamune Makabe,
and I'm Aki Aragaki. I'm good at Japanese. I learned it somewhere. I
studied a lot from the Nohay anime and manga. I
have shoes.
It's a manga.
[Music] It's
amazing.
Whenever my brother goes to Tokyo for work, he always
asks me to buy him a lot of manga. He's an
otaku, and I want to be able to write manga like that someday.
You're
right.  In this country, there
is also a manga called Band Stopping, but
what kind of manga do I want to
write? [Music] You wrote it.
[Music]
For me, the pop of Tsumire, who lives in Tokyo, makes my
heart flutter.  I want to write a romantic comedy.The
heroes' names are Tsumire and Chikuwan.My favorite
Japanese food is oden.
[Music]